[Musique]
bonjour à tous
hier j'étais avec la patronne plume
apparaître votre projet là le haut mais
à domicile on fait le proto balancer vos
idées on commence sur une idée d'un
propriétaire c'est la main c pour
attraper des trucs avec sonne pas mal
pas mal est-ce qu'il ya des griffes pour
déchiqueter les froisser trop violente
pas des griffes toi ah oui pardon alors
moi j'ai le nombril
alors voici un trou dans le ventre qui
fait alors jamais fini voilà c'est ça je
verrais bien les petites boules auch qui
traînent dans le besoin de tuer on m'a
par contre j'ai un trou qui sert à
quelque chose
ça sert à l'évacuation des déchets
admirait s'il vous plaît tout l'anus or
quoi maintenant regardez c'est un petit
charme quand même cache-cache moi ça
cache mal ses poils autour de dents et
où des pointes de donc mais c'est
dégueulasse mais temaru faut bien
quelqu'un qui pense aux déchets pour ses
atouts qui font rêver sur l'homme je
sais pas moi
l'oeil à beloeil est d'accord c'est pour
voir
non mais combien et bâton mais un gros
lot au milieu du visage saxe est non
mais on va en mettre deux ados c'est
bien c'est raisonnable oui
qu'est ce que tu as oui alors moi
j'avais le pied c'est quoi le pied c'est
comme la main mais en bas au pour
attraper les trucs sans se baisser c'est
bien foraine ah non non non ça très peu
rien mais ça n'a pas de doigts alors si
il ya des doigts mais trop petit pour
attraper quelque chose on peut dire
peut-être qu'à la fin de la journée
ça sent pas bon le pied une main qui pue
4 après un non mais c'est un pack mobile
ou pas bon moi j'avais pensé aux
sourcils mesures annoncées sarasar est
en cours de l'entretien là et on n'a pas
parlé des sexes moi j'ai bossé sur un
truc ça s'appelle baveux
c'est tout équipé à l'intérieur
vrai que tori système de flore auto
watch un petit bijou comprend que dalle
alors moi j'ai bossé aussi pas mal hein
le pénis c'est vraiment cette force
d'annoncés bien avec les héros et tout
si on prend ça le penalty j'ai passé la
mission de jack valentine a dessiné un
pénis en dessous ok ok on va apprendre
les deux on va prendre les deux ça pour
l'homme ça pour la femme est à quai ce
qu'il parte le bd ballom bref faut
porter des choses c'est lors des 7 sur 7
sur 9 mois c'est douloureux ça laisse
des vergetures et ce qu'il vaut mieux
d'ailleurs j'avais pensé pour nourrir le
bébé avec du lait
le téton pour la pharma lesquels contre
la faim dans l'espace et pourquoi pas
pour les hommes
même s'il faut parler du coût non mais
pas pour les hommes voilà en faudra deux
ou trois points au tour quand même
peut-être de notre ça dans un coin j'ai
un autre truc c'est les selles regardez
c'est en dessous du bras voilà j remis
quelques balles mais j'ai une direction
artistique j'imagine que ce sont mauvais
à la journée lisez ça très bien qu ont
du coup pour sentir j'avais pensé le nez
on pourra football a donc avec deux
trous pour l'espagne sinon l'intestin
l'intestin j'avais pensé à ça c'est une
sorte de tuyau pour traiter la
nourriture
ah ah ça c'est bien c'est important ça
n'a pas pensé à ça par la nourriture ou
un tuyau pour la nourriture l'intestin
le félon commandes
cependant on peut pas une petite envie
d'être folle envie non non non non c'est
quoi ton mètre soixante maxi non non ça
s'arrangera je sais quoi qui a contrario
mais bonjour quatre hommes qui les
motifs salle est comble jour battre nous
vous en fines tranches sur l'épaule
mais enfin pas du tout c'est victor haïm
branches sèches mon phasmes est adorable
regardez caresse le holà attention
qu'est-ce qui a inventé cette merde
renner et s'est effectuée comme une
image pas bougé à bouger alors c'est
quoi 40e ra jamais mais non mais c'est
le tuyau pour la nourriture 11 et cuit m
ça rentre pas dans l'eau ni su que ça
rentre on passe on se démerde ou au bout
en lambeaux bidon tournicote on voit un
produit des solutions à bercy quand on
veut que ça rentre à rentrer et au bout
du tuyau on pourrait rajouter mon fameux
non non non non tout ça c'est bien ça
génial ça troue ben oui je pense c'est
plutôt la plaie de l'anus mais pourquoi
pas mais cette avenue ses voûtes robin
êtes bien et c'est vrai qu'il par contre
qui a inventé les poils c'est une bonne
idée ça c'est petit paul partout là ces
petits cheveux de taille moyenne
ah c'est vous bon eh ben c'est bien vous
êtes embauché et vous bat vous vous
étiez un chef de projet me dit voilà et
à leurs proches qui les hommes alors
éclaté vous j'adore
1 vous m'en fait de toutes les tailles
tous les poids toutes les couleurs et va
causer toutes les couleurs vous ne
sortez pas en violet vaniteux bleu m1
ont fait 3 1 bleu comme ça de mer de la
bande des biens dits donc niveau poil je
pense qu'on pouvait en mettre
éventuellement sur les bras sur les
mains sur les doigts sur les doigts de
pieds au sujet des décors je pensais je
vous entendu là on parle et il faut en
mettre sur les zones aussi hein sinon ça
fait vide ça fait pas fini à les
lutteurs on y va avec l'état
vous avez raison tout une branche
[Musique]